my name's james from mountain rock
cleaning and today i'm going to be
cleaning a rug infested with earthworms
the rug was just completely saturated in
mud soaking wet and then on further
inspection i could see what looked to be
little maggots inside the rug turns out
it was probably earthworm larvae it was
a rug that somebody didn't want anymore
so it was just discarded in their garden
basically i just wanted to see if i
could clean it test my skills
essentially and and see you know what i
could do with it
essentially i'm just rinsing the rug
with water so it's just a high-powered
hose and it's just pushing water out
onto the rug to just rinse out as much
of the of the mud as possible
it's not a pressure washer pressure
washer has a lot of power but it doesn't
necessarily shoot out a high volume of
water onto the rug and essentially what
you want to do in the beginning is just
get the water on there as quick as
possible i have a pump attached to the
hose
just so it gives enough pressure and
power so it's not like trickling out
really slowly it's powerful enough that
you can
sort of blast the top of the the rug and
it will just sort of wash away any sort
of um surface soils from the top of the
rug
you're going to be using brushes on the
rug and the water alongside with the
shampoo lubricates the rug to
prevent any kind of damage from from the
machines that you're going to be using
on it all sorts of leaves and twigs and
soil and things are just blasting off
the top of the rug as well as the
earthworms that were in there i wanted
to make sure that i got those washed off
the top of the rug because i didn't want
to turn them all up into the rod so i
wanted to make sure that i got those all
off first before i took any more steps
i'm using just a watering can with a
mixture of
shampoo and
oxygen booster in it and then i'm just
using that to just get the shampoo
distributed over the top of the rug
so that's the rotary machine it has a
rotating brush on the bottom of it and
that is used to essentially get the
shampoo mixed into the rug
so it's easier to then wash out i'm
using a special fibre shampoo it's quite
a mild detergent
pet safe wall safe it's not very strong
it's just enough to break down the soils
in the rug and make it easier for you to
sort of wash it all out
the oxygen booster just helps break down
the soils a lot quicker it can make
things whiter it can bring the colors
out reduce odor and yeah just
essentially make it easier for you to
remove the stains
i wouldn't use bleach at all bleach in
general damages the fibers especially
because this was a wool rug it can
damage the colors in the rug so it's
better to just avoid using the bleach
it's cold water you don't want to use
hot water on rugs because
they tend to have a
problem with shrinking so
you just use cold water and that just
eliminates any kind of potential
problems that you might have with
cleaning them
[Music]
you then use what's called a squeegee
essentially like what you use to clean
your windows and you you scrape off all
the dirt and foam from the top of the
rug
the next step is flipping the rug over
and then cleaning the wash floor
underneath because a lot of the dirt and
stuff is still underneath the rug so i
think it's a good idea to just wash all
that away before you then put the rug
back on top that you've just cleaned
and then again it's pretty much exactly
the same process as doing the front just
start off with getting the rug saturated
with water adding the shampoo and an
oxygen booster again and then just
cleaning back of it with the rotary to
get as many of the stains out as you
possibly can
always clean the back in the front
because when you clean the front it
pushes a lot of the dirt through into
the back
and then also on the flip side when you
clean the bat it then forces a lot of
the
dirt and stuff which is deep in the rug
out from the opposite side if you see
what i mean
[Music]
i usually then use a crb machine on on
the top of the rug it looks a bit like a
vacuum it's like a gray box
it stands for contra rotating brush head
inside it's got two brushes that revolve
in opposite directions and then as they
roll up they they sort of pull the
fibers of the rug up into the machine so
it kind of gives you a much deeper clean
but it also lifts the pile of the rug
making it a bit more fluffy
i'm adding more products to the rug to
sort of break down more soils that are
still left inside you do it until the
water comes out as clear as possible
you'll never get a rug 100 clean there
will always be some dirt inside a rug
you could be using
thousands and thousands of liters of
water unnecessarily for very very little
gain
so there's a point at which it's still
getting little bits out but it's just
not worth wasting so much water in order
to get it out
at that point i'm adding acidic rinse to
the rug it neutralizes all the
chemicals that you've previously used
and it helps to wash them all out it
also helps prevent cellulosic browning
which is a process at which the natural
fibers in the rug can can turn
brown that is called a gandy groom it's
used to remove the pattern left in the
rug but it's also to set the fibres to
help it dry quicker
i'm vacuuming out as much moisture as i
possibly can so that's basically a wet
vac and it's sucking out the moisture
and then it's going into a tank
it's quite an important process because
it is obviously removing a lot of the
moisture from the rug then i put it in a
centrifuge which gets about 95 of the
water out of the rug you hang the rug in
a
warm room with fans and a dehumidifier
and then that just gets the last
remaining bits of the moisture out
i mean don't leave your rug in the
garden
for a start
um but yeah the biggest tip i've got for
taking care of your rug is is lots of
vacuuming the worst thing that damages
the rug is probably the dry soils in the
rug for long periods of time it kind of
can wear down the rug so
lots of vacuuming and and regular
beating
i didn't really feel comfortable with
then giving it on to somebody else so
after i'd cleaned it rather than just
throwing it in the bin and wasting it i
thought a good thing to do would be to
give it to a dog shower so that's what i
did